I think a lot of people think of the
parties no longer serving their
interests were their desires it happens
it's happened before in American history
plenty of times parties are always
coalition's anyway so there's always
somebody who's feeling as if they're not
getting you know not being served well
by the party but it's gotten to be a
real cleavage these days one of the big
reasons 2008 which was a big big year
looking back on it I mean not only the
financial crash but Obama's election
Obama's election really signaled the end
of the culture war that had been driving
Republican politics for a very long time
I mean it meant it was it was going to
be over I'll continue but really
rearguard actions but that was it and
then the crash I mean you know in
American history the question of
inequality has been a perennial we think
of it now is something that suddenly
come up but it's been a perennial it's
always there the idea that somehow vast
inequalities of wealth in particular are
dangerous for a democracy there's
nothing new but the idea kind of you
know it submerges consumers for very
long time and it did submerge for a long
time in 2008 brought it right back up
again with a ferocity that we're seeing
on the campaign trail today the very
beginning of American history American
politics the question of slavery and
race was there from the very beginning
and you know it was it was actually
being agitated although with the margins
at first it was later going to become
more mainstream so that's always an
aspect of American politics the question
of slavery and its its legacy in
American political history the economics
I mean yeah I mean from the very
beginning Washington's administration
arguments about how the country should
questions about where the country should
be headed what kind of country we are
supposed to be there was there was some
thought that by you know bringing in a
moneyed class by building a moneyed
class to consolidate the economy that's
the Hamiltonian view there were others
who thought that no power and economics
really ought to be decentralized more
than just the Jeffersonian view more
spread around that's putting it very
crudely but that's kind of what it was
it was an issue from the very start and
you can see that issue playing its
out we've seen in American history there
have been divergences in convergences
the period in American history for
example after World War two historians
and economists call it the great
compression the great convergence where
vast inequalities left over from the
1910s 1920s actually began to narrow and
that continued right into the 1970s so
American politics and it's about
politics primarily has had the means and
the ways to flatten those differences to
make them less garish unless to make
them to make them less severe than later
than they then they've normally been
since the 1970s there's been a pressure
towards divergence it really began to
take off during the 1980s and Reagan
Reagan's policies made a big big
difference in terms of not only tax
policy but in terms of deregulation as
well we're seeing the fruits of all that
the bitter fruits of all that in two
thousand in the 2000s and the
deregulation and the financial collapse
in 2008 only made it worse so political
decisions that the country made and the
policies that followed after that has
enormous consequences
you